bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week-end le magazine dédié à vos sorties
et vos loisirs
au sommaire de ce numéro l'association
imagine fort margot propose un nouveau
rendez-vous pour sensibiliser à la lutte
contre les cancers pédiatriques sur
trappe
et là c'est aussi un cours de zumba
comme chaque année le château de
versailles reçoit une grande exposition
d'art contemporain
cette année c'est le danois olafur
eliasson qui présente ses oeuvres et à
plaisir samedi sur la question de
voyages et de fait comme chaque année
depuis 14 ans la commune organise escale
d'ailleurs un festival familial et pour
notre premier rendez-vous du week-end
nous prenons la direction de trappes et
du gymnase broustal ce samedi un cours
de zumba un peu particulier est proposé
nous allons en parler avec notre
première invitée christine de fuster
bonjour bonjour vous êtes ambassadrice
de l'association imagine fort margot
cette association mène des actions de
sensibilisation et des collectes de
fonds pour aider la recherche européenne
autour des cancers pédiatriques imagine
forme un organisme de nombreux rendez
vous sur saint quentin et notamment sur
trappe
là c'est un cours de zumba comment ça va
se passer alors demain il ya neuf
professeurs coachée par aminata diallo
qui vont venir mettre le feu dans le
gymnase pour la recherche sur les
cancers pédiatriques
on l'a déjà fait l'année dernière avec
aminata elle a répondu présente pour la
deuxième fois et ses généreuses
personnes viennent à nouveau demain
voilà tout le monde peut y participer la
zumba où il faudra carrément une
certaine contre alors on a dit à partir
de 10 ans et puis ouais il faut quand
même avoir un peu la pêche parce qu'ils
sont un peu ils ont la pêche
donc après chacun le fait à son rythme
on n'est pas obligé de faire vite quoi
vous dit il au pluriel parce qu'en fait
les professeurs seront neuf voiliers de
15 heures à 17 heures c'est un gros
rendez vous oui c'est un gros
rendez-vous et beaucoup de pub faite sur
les réseaux sociaux et les routes le
retenait retour que je vois là sur
facebook entre août promet beaucoup de
monde et c'est superbe c'est le moyen
pour vous outre de proposer une activité
sympathique a fait rentrer en famille on
a mis entre amis de proposer une
certaine sensibilisation
voilà ça ça me plaît de sensibiliser
et les gens sur ce sujet grave avec
beaucoup d'énergie et de joie demain
mais derrière tout ça il ya quand même
un sujet grave qu'est le cancer des
enfants qui malheureusement est le
dernier wagon de la recherche dernier
wagon de la rocha vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus pour qu'on se
rend compte du panorama alors en effet
il ya gall 2 % de la recherche médicale
consacrée aux enfants la recherche elle
est financée par des fonds publics et
des associations
malheureusement les laboratoires ne
suivent pas pas encore
ils sont en train de collaborer de
discuter peut-être que ça va changer
j'espère dans les mois qui viennent dans
les années qui viennent
on essaie de faire changer la
réglementation européenne pour que les
laboratoires soient obligés de
participer ses actions et par des
actions comme ce cours sa ns et ça vous
permet aussi de sensibiliser le public
vers un écho plus large que finalement
peut-être les simples laboratoire ben en
fait moi j'ai un de mes enfants qui a eu
un cancer et pour tout vous dire je
savais pas que ça existait pour les
enfants c'était en 1996 le temps a passé
mais il ya encore des gens aujourd'hui
qui qui sont étonnés que ce soit quand
même la première cause de décès par
maladie chez l'enfant et comment ça va
se passer demain le cours commence il ya
des panneaux d'information c'est vous
mêmes cadeaux auprès du pub à leurs lots
main il ya un accueil dans le hall du
gymnase avec vente des goodies ventes de
l'entrée qui sera de 15 euros
on paye qu'à partir de 15 ans en dessous
de 15 ans les enfants sont accueillis
gratuitement
ensuite je vais faire une présentation
de l'association de cinq minutes et
après je vais laisser place à la fête
15 euros l'entrée tous les fonds sont
reversés ou une partie sert aussi à
financer la préparation aux 90 où les
fonds sont reversés tout le reste c'est
nous avec mes amis qui m'ont acheté du
papier pour faire des supers banderole
enfin bref les boissons seront offertes
à la fin du cours sont des mamans de
trappes qui font des gâteaux donc il ya
un gros mouvement de solidaires
solidaire à trappes pour plein de
raisons plein d'associations mais en
l'occurrence pour imagine forme argos et
demain il venait souvent sur trappe
c'est vous avez un lien en particulier
que la commune oui moi ça fait dix ans
que je suis maître nageur à la piscine
de trappes
g j'aime beaucoup
solidarité qui a dans cette ville les
gens répondent présents sont venus à mes
actions depuis trois ans et reviennent
ils sont contents donc je trouve ça
super de le montrer sous ce jour pour
venir
si quelqu'un se décide de venir au
dernier moment il peut où il ya des
inscriptions affaire où un numéro d'été
pas d'inscription vous pouvez sur la
page facebook for the life marqué un
petit message mais vous venez il ya 3 il
ya un grand parking à plus 300 places de
parking le gymnase est très grand donc
il n'y a pas d'inscription non on amène
quoi sa bonne humeur ces chaussées ans
et les choses folles fillon ça me laisse
dresscode bleus et roses et une
bouteille d'eau surtout une bouteille
d'eau voilà et sa bonne humeur
voilà merci l'artiste r nous présenter
ce rendez vous on le disait donc samedi
11 juin sera donc l'occasion de
s'essayer à la zumba tout en s'informant
sur les cancers pédiatriques et de faire
un don par la même occasion le cours est
proposé par imagine fort margot il est
donné au gymnase broustal de trappes
ça se passe de 15 heures à 17 heures et
l'accueil par contre se fait dès 14h30 à
faire merci
pour cette page exposition nous partons
tout d'abord à versailles puisque après
l'exposition contemporaine de l'année
d'année deux dernières d'anish kapoor le
château accueille aulas furent eliasson
avec cinq dispositifs jouant sur
l'illusion d'optique l'artiste danois
propose une perception de l'espace
modifié sephora n'amène vous en donne un
avant goût et les images sont signés
patrick jacques de dixmude
cinq dispositifs déployant un jeu de
miroirs et de lumière viennent
d'intégrer le château de versailles un
moyen pour la furent eliasson n'ont
rappelé que la cour a toujours été à
versailles un lieu d'observation
constante de soi même et des autres
l'artiste contemporain est l'invité du
roi soleil jusqu'au 30 octobre
j'avais envie d'intégrer la scène dans
une chambre de miroirs et j'avais plutôt
envie de montrer un dispositif optique
c'était très ambitieux et j'avais envie
de travailler avec cette atmosphère avec
ce jardin j'avais envie de connecter le
jardin avec quelque chose de très léger
les créations extérieur forme d'un
triptyque autour du thème de l'eau voit
les circulaires de fin brouillard tapis
de résidus de glaciers du groenland dans
le bosquet de la colonnade et
installation d'une cascade dans laxe du
grand canal ces oeuvres contemporaines
dilue l'agencement formelle des jardins
et établissent une nouvelle perception
de l'espace
je pense que l'exemple l'art
contemporain s'est installé à versailles
depuis bientôt une décennie maintenant
que il correspond
à l'idée même qu'avait louis xiv en
construisant versailles l'idée d'en
faire le lieu de la création
le lieu de l'innovation d'y inviter des
artistes des scientifiques d'inviter des
étrangers à venir montrer leur
savoir-faire à versailles on ne fait que
tirer ce fil les huit dispositif de
l'artiste danois ont été réalisés dans
son atelier à berlin avec le concours
des équipes du château de versailles
ces oeuvres viennent s'ajouter aux
nombreuses créations déjà exposé au
musée d'art moderne de paris au tate
modern de londres et au moma de new york
du côté de l'ancienne une exposition
touche à sa fin la maison de l'étang de
la commune présente jusqu'au 12 juin les
travaux de dec un artiste plurimédia
immobile le nom de l'exposition
s'intéresse à léquilibre regarder pour
se réaliser des cas besoin de mixer les
genres et les médias d'intégrer les
technologies les plus contemporaines à
son art l'artiste pluri média présente
son exposition hymne mobile à la maison
de l'étang de louveciennes peintures
sculptures installations un travail
éclectique mais qui reste axée autour de
la thématique de l' équilibre s'est
trouvé dans une sculpture de un point
d'équilibré
là il y en a une on se dit ça tient oui
ça tient mais ça pourrait s'écrouler et
une toile c'est pareil il y a il ya un
équilibre il ya un équilibre entre les
entre les couleurs entre les le
la disposition de la couleur sur la sur
la toile la façon dont ça a été disposé
il y à une installation derrière avec
des miroirs un jeu de courants d'air des
led pour que ça bouge pour qu'il ya un
retour sur le plafond de la lumière on
voit de la lumière
donc tout est question d'équilibré après
une formation aux beaux-arts et en école
de design deck de son vrai nom
christophe julien allie travail sur bois
résume pierre toile et lun une réflexion
sur les effets de matière et de
contraste pour jouer avec les volumes
le volume est important et je pense
qu'une exposition pour qu'elle soit
vivante aujourd'hui il faut également
intégrer une mise en scène et c'est vrai
que je fais également la mise en scène
de mes expositions et c'est vrai qu'on
est dans des salles messadia des murs
neufs habiller les murs mais il ya des
espaces entre les murs
cette exposition est à découvrir
jusqu'au 12 juin à l'ancienne prochain
rendez vous dans les yvelines pour
l'artiste à partir du 16 janvier à
l'espace des arts de villennes sur seine
on continue ce statut de week end votre
magazine dédié à vos sorties et vos
loisirs avec nos deux nouveaux invités
les deux deux communes organise ce
week-end des fêtes samedi plus
précisément nous parlerons tout à
l'heure de la 14e édition du festival
escales d'ailleurs qui se tient à
plaisir philippe korda maire adjoint en
charge déléguée à la culture et aux
manifestations nous présentera le
programme
bonjour je mets avant d'aller à plaisir
on part à voisins le bretonneux puisque
dans la commune samedi après midi les
enfants sont à la fête
nathalie ferré plus bonjour vous êtes la
maire-adjointe en charge notamment des
centres de loisirs et de la petite
enfance de la commune alors une grosse
après-midi juste pour les enfants d'où
est venue l'idée
alors voilà donc c'est notre deuxième
édition en 2015
écoutez on a décidé d'innover en la
matière et on a décidé de présenter
toute une année de travail des équipes
dédiées à la petite enfance
donc ça fait suite à la programmation
des temps périscolaires qui avait été
mis en place et on a associé la petite
enfance avec les crèches et les
structures de garderie municipale puis
les assistantes maternelles
voilà on a regroupé tous les
intervenants on leur a demandé de nous
concocter un événement pour que les
enfants retrouvent un petit peu ce
qu'ils ont fait tout au long de l'année
et le présente à leurs familles ils vont
présenter quoi des spectacles des
petites saynètes des expositions alors
en fait ces multiples il ya une
exposition donc dans la maison de
coville qui va présenter les oeuvres des
enfants des différents centres de
loisirs de la ville des petits travaux
effectués aussi par les enfants des
structures petite enfance
et puis dans le jardin jeanne fleuret
dans la cour de covile à l'intérieur de
la salle de la tour des ateliers qui
reprennent ce qu'ils ont découvert tout
au long de l'année c'est un moyen c'est
de mettre à l'honneur les plus jeunes de
la commune est montré ce qu'ils font
pour faire vivre la commune aussi alors
un moyen de mettre les plus jeunes à
l'honneur ainsi que toutes les équipes
éducatif qui les accompagnent au
quotidien
c'est un travail exceptionnel j'invite
tous les vices ynwa et tous les tous les
habitants du territoire à venir c'est
une fête ouverte à tous
l'exposition dans la maison de covile
sera prolongée jusqu'à mercredi
donc vraiment
c'est un moment de partage de
convivialité et d'un niveau relationnel
exceptionnel un partage et convivialité
qui commence dès midi avec un pique
nique
voilà alors le pique nique familial donc
chaque famille amène son pique nique et
sera invité à s'installer dans le jardin
jeanne fleuret des chaises longues ont
été prévus les arbres sont là pour
prêter l'ombre âge si le dieu soleil
veut bien nous honorer de sa présence
et puis après à 14 heures l'ouverture
des festivités et une conclusion qui a
été préparé pour les familles et leurs
enfants avec le bal de la compagnie dont
j'ai oublié le nom
donc qui s'appelle la compagnie mambo
swing tagada vont parler c'est un
travail sur toute l'année avec les
centres oui vous au sein avec les
acteurs ça a été long 6 à mettre en
place pour trouver quoi faire pour
animer alors trouver quoi faire non mais
ce qui a été long ça a été de préparer
toute la coordination de toutes les
équipes qui ont l'habitude de travailler
chacune de leur côté est là et bien on a
fait interagir les équipes entre elle et
ça aussi c'est très important de générer
de la synergie entre nos équipes qui
sont dédiés aux enfants tout au long de
l'année et vous faites ça aussi dans la
maison de commune et autour qui est un
lieu fort de la commune oui centrale
c'est le lieu de c'est un de nos lieux
de patrimoine historique majeur le
jardin jeanne fleuret c'est un jardin
public que l'on dédie à cette fête ce
jour-là extrêmement bucolique
qui permet de recevoir tout le monde
dans une ambiance détendue familial et
parmi les acteurs il y en a un peu
particulier vous recevez vous accueillez
un apiculteur vie si noir on peut m'en
dire un peu plus oui bien sûr alors là
l'équipe municipale a fait le choix en
2014 d'implanter trois ruches au parc de
la croix du bois pour que ces ruches
soit exploité correctement
nous avons fait appel à un avis un
apiculteur et grande chance nous avons
investi noah qui veut rester anonyme
mais qui est un apiculteur avec qui la
mairie a contracté pour l'exploitation
des ruches et samedi ce sera la
dégustation de la première récolte 100%
médine croix du bois voisins le
bretonneux
vous n'avez pas encore eu l'honneur des
goûters vous allez découvrir ça ce
week-end car voilà c'est une grande
première nous allons offrir à tous le
plaisir de découvrir et d'un point de
vue pratique il y a des inscriptions ou
l'entrée est libre
non il n'y a aucune inscription c'est
libre à partir de 12h jusqu'à la clôture
par le spectacle mais les enfants ne
sont pas laissés
avec les animateurs les paras les
enfants sont sous la surveillance des
parents qui eux mêmes auront le plaisir
de participer aux ateliers et comment
parler des centres de loisirs et de la
petite enfance
est-ce qu'il ya quand même un âge limite
peut-être fait les grands chez les plus
petits pour pour les années mais non
c'est vraiment la fête de l'enfance les
grands frères et grandes soeurs les
anciens d'éclat ne peuvent participer
merci nathalie fait la langue si vous
terminez près je veux oui je veux vous
apporter une précision parce que cette
fête est là une autre connotation nous
allons offrir en partenariat avec le
golf de buc une animation golfique
alors ça c'est la première animation de
voisins en route pour la ryder cup c'est
à dire que là c'est le point de départ
de différentes animations
d'ici les deux prochaines années pour
que voisin soit aussi la ville de la
razer puisque la ryder cup se tiendra en
voilà une fois le territoire donc le
golf est à manille mais quelque part on
est déjà un voisin donc pour nous c'est
aussi un événement majeur que de lancer
les préparatifs de la ryder cup
merci nathalie fait réplique donc pour
découvrir le golf découvre goûter la
première le premier miel vie si noah et
pour les viennois qui voudrait juste
faire la fête avec leur famille et leurs
amis la fête des enfants commence donc
dès midi avec un pique nique avant de
proposer tout un tas d'animations
rendez vous samedi 11 juin à la maison
de covile conférence au on va à plaisir
avec tu sais les cordes à ce que là il
sera question d'un voyage d'armes de
tous les arts à travers le monde vous
proposer la carte la 14e édition des
escales d'ailleurs un rendez vous
immanquable maintenant pour les pl les
plaisirs war oui effectivement c'est
près de dix à douze mille personnes qui
viennent chaque année cette 14e édition
reprend les standards et offre comme
d'habitude quelques nouveautés on en
parle tout au long de l'année avec nos
plaisirs oies qui attendent avec
impatience l'événement mais aussi avec
les associations qui sont des acteurs
forts et du partenaire même de
l'événement
c'est une journée placée sous le signe
de la fête du voyage on voit l'image en
dernier
il y avait des déambulations
effectivement l'idée c'est de présenter
les cultures du monde à travers quatre
pôles principaux donc la danse la
musique les jeux mais aussi des
déambulations des expositions qui vont
permettre un petit peu à tous les
visiteurs de se promener de voyages et
de rêver de participer et de contribuer
à cette fête familiale
vous parlez de nouveautés quelles sont
elles alors s'il ya quelques surprises
donc voilà il faut donner quelques
petites choses alors on a une projets
importants sur la ville cette année qui
est les fresques du vally bout donc
c'est un projet partenariat avec l'opéra
la ville et puis les habitants pour
construire et préparer des fresques sur
les murs de leur résidence
et donc nous allons avoir le privilège
de dévoiler les premières maquettes donc
de ses fresques
c'est un projet que vous suivez
régulièrement et pour lequel on a
vraiment bien sûr une grande fierté et
on sera très content de les montrer à
l'ensemble des plaisirs oies et pas
seulement aux habitants du quartier
et puis une deuxième nouveauté c'est
dans le cadre du jumelage on a une
association très active aussi avec les
villes de geesthacht être cool riga en
lettonie et là ils viendront sur le pole
dance nous offrir un peu de danse
folklorique et puis du hip hop à la le
monde voit la petite surprise à
découvrir escale d'ailleurs c'est une
fête proposée par la mairie mais
il est tous les acteurs de la commune
sont mis en avant il ya les
les clubs les associations mais tout à
fait alors évidemment il ya une grosse
machine une grosse infrastructure qui
fait travailler les nombreux services de
la ville que je remercie par avance mais
aussi il ya une participation très forte
des associations aussi bien sur les
pôles artistiques ce soit musique ou
danse mais aussi au pôle gastronomique
puisque on a la chance d'avoir beaucoup
d'associations qui sont prêtes nous
faire partager leurs spécialités
culinaires
donc c'est un lieu aussi où il est
classique qu'on se retrouve entre amis
pour dîner le soir ou pour grignoter
tout au long de la journée
voilà et puis ce qui est important aussi
c'est qu'on a le conservatoire de la
ville qui est un acteur important et
l'après midi en particulier à la fois la
scène dance et la scène musique leur
seront dédiées pour quelques
représentations du travail de l'année
des lieux pour les enfants avec des
petits jeux ils sont à nouveau là sa
table et oui oui bien sûr alors cessé
des jeux toujours plébiscité parce que
c'est des jeux qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir il ya du bois du volume on va
pouvoir escalader en toute sécurité
donc là aussi c'est important pour les
tout-petits puis il est un petit peu
plus grand évidemment c'est plus tôt
dans l'après-midi mais là on est dans le
standard je dirais de l'autre des jeux
l'an dernier plus de 10000 oui
participants enfin deux personnes qui
ont fait le déplacement
vous espérez la même fréquentation bien
sûr le soleil sera au rendez vous comme
d'habitude
bon on aura peut-être une ou deux
petites averses mais où il suffira de
mettre un parapluie pendant pendant
l'ondé tout tout se passera très bien
j'en profite pour dire aussi qu'ils
aient des navettes gratuites depuis la
gare c'est important puisque toutes les
heures du rhin un flot de plaisir oies
ou même des voisins deux voisins ou
d'ailleurs qui pourront nous rejoindre
facilement parce que évidemment il y
aura quelques difficultés de circulation
mais vous imaginez les dix mille
personnes qui se regroupent au parc du
château forcément faux faut s'organiser
il est simple conseiller peut-être de se
garer un peu plus loin de chercher à
aller au château voilà exactement c'est
pas très loin il ya plusieurs parkings
qui seront fléchés et puis cette année
on sera un petit peu contraints de faire
un contrôle de sécurité à l'entrée
mais rassurez-vous tout se passera bien
et on vous attend nombreux et pour ceux
qui seraient absents ce week-end qu'ils
ne pourraient pas se déplacer réserve
escale d'ailleurs une quinzième édition
est déjà dans les cartons
oui alors c'est devenu incontournable
comme tout le monde nous le demandent
simplement on cesse et budgétairement
parlant c est un coût pour la commune
puisque l'on souhaite vraiment offrir
avec notre maire et le conseil municipal
1 une journée gratuite
un événement important et donc du coup
on travaille depuis deux ans maintenant
pour en réduire les coûts de façon
significative à réduire le budget de 20%
déjà et puis on fait appel à des
sponsors
un petit un petit clin d'oeil on
souhaite la depuis l'année dernière
introduire un petit peu de numérique
donc des jeux avec smartphone qui
permettront aux jeunes donc de vivre
autrement le festival est donc là on
fait appel à des entreprises qui
voudraient nous accompagner dans cette
démarche
merci si des cordes à nous avoir fait
découvrir cette 14ème édition
donc on le rappelle c'est samedi 11 juin
là aussi la fête commence à 14 heures
dans le parc du château
on le disait pour des questions de
sécurité liées en l'état d'urgence
notamment des contrôles seront mis en
place aux entrées donc prévoyez un petit
peu d'avancé sur vos déplacements pour
ne pas rater ce que vous avez coché dans
l'agenda
si c'est dans les salles obscures que
vous souhaitez vous rendre syrie la date
de l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois vous présente son coup
de coeur pour les gouttes
cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film elle réalisé par paul verhoeven
avec isabelle huppert
michel fait partie de ces femmes que
rien ne semble atteindre à la tête d'une
grande entreprise de jeux vidéo elle
gère ses affaires comme sa vie
sentimentale d'une main de fer sa vie
bascule lorsqu'elle est agressée chez
elle par mystérieuse inconnue
inébranlable michel se met à le traquer
en retour un jeu étrange s'installe
alors entre eux un jeu qui à tout
instant peut dégénérer
elle signe le retour d'un paul verhoven
plus que jamais passé maître dans l'art
de déranger pour son premier tournage en
france le réalisateur de base'
christique mène son dernier thriller
avec une virtuosité emballante du maquis
qu il fallait tout le talent d'isabelle
huppert pour incarner à la perfection ce
sublime portrait d'une femme qui
dissimule ses failles
son interprétation est vraiment
exceptionnel à la fois drôle et choquant
le film est un suspense à l'américaine
elle est interdit aux moins de 12 ans et
est à découvrir cette semaine à l'espace
philippe noiret ont conclu cette page
cinéma avec cette fois les sorties de la
semaine à camille lambert et manon la
bad sont allés recueillir vos avis vos
coups de coeur ou vos déceptions
c'est très bien c'est un film un peu
psyché au début parce que leur on
s'attend quand même dès la deuxième
partie est très bien très bien en
planche
un bon film bien jouer super film tout
le scénario l'histoire c'est vraiment de
du moment en fin de de la vie de c'est
super bluffant l'image tout l'image du
film est génial
les acteurs le jeu d'acteur est une
magnifique donc voilà franchement un
très bon film l'euro de football
commence le vendredi 10 juin si vous
n'avez pas obtenu les précieux sésames
pour voir les matchs directement dans le
stade de nombreux lieux proposent des
retransmissions on vous propose un petit
tour d'horizon
et on commence tout de suite par le
gymnase pierre de coubertin à montigny
du 18 au 24 les matches de l'euro seront
retransmis sur écran géant à l'occasion
du village foot on passe au bail sec
leur faim quand on devienne le nouveau
restaurant situé à côté du vélodrome
pourra recevoir plus de 140 personnes à
montigny le bistrot du théâtre installé
des grands écrans et habiller la
structure aux couleurs de la france cap
à présent sur voisin le bar le frappe se
diffusera l'ensemble de la compétition
sur grand écran
une cinquantaine de supporters est
attendu à chaque match le barreau dans
le pâtis vous accueille du mardi au
dimanche dans une ambiance irlandaise
c'est l'idéal pour suivre les matchs des
britanniques à mort pâle viennent bikaï
vote diffusera tous les matches de
l'équipe de france et les matches
importants après les poules à guyancourt
urban soccer proposera des écrans géants
plus de 300 m² pour jouer aussi à
versailles le bar en nombre on
projettera les matches de l'euro sur
grand écran coup juge jouvencelles
toujours à versailles le bar pub au
paris proposera comme à chaque grande
compétition les matchs en direct écrans
plats seront installés et enfin on
termine avec rambouillet où le bar
napoléon diffusera l'intégralité de la
compétition
voilà le 7-8 week-end est maintenant
terminée la semaine prochaine c'est
mikel et demi d'euros qui vous donnera
des idées sorties et loisirs
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week end